you
what I like to tell people is if all the
exams I've taken over the years I think
of the bar exam in New York and Rhode
Island I think in the medical license
exams I think in the gre's to get into
graduate school and taking a notary
public exam in New York State the
hardest exam by far which the new york
city tour guiding exam so if you were
planning on becoming a new york city
tour guide get your blue book and study
hard it was all stood when i was most
proud to have passed that being said
I've given some walking tours in New
York one of my dreams is fit someday
when I retire I'll be on one of those
red double-decker buses sharing my love
of New York because I i do love New York
and I think it is the greatest city in
the world at least for me to live in my
favorite monument is a rather obscure
monument but few people even know of
that I've written about in the past is
the amiable child monument at riverside
drive at 104 hundred and thirty third
street it's a little grave marker that's
been there for about 250 years on that
300 years excuse me it marks the place
or a child in the late 18th century fell
off the cliff and died badtameez rural
farmland it was a strawberry field not
much is known about the child but over
the centuries people from a neighborhood
and increasingly people from a city come
to that site to pay tribute to things
they've lost them a city or to share
their own experiences and miss little
museum so to speak around this grave
site of trinkets and Christopher's
medals and heirlooms and after nine
eleven people from the neighborhood came
there and you could still see sense to
smell of the burning buildings from
downtown whacking up the Hudson and
people left tribute to their and pin
letters there and it's a truly haunting
site that if you were ever in
Morningside Heights birthday
you